How the 20/20 Vision Scale Works
With more than 150 million people in the United
States (nearly half of the population) requiring
some form of corrective eyewear to compensate
for visual impairment, chances are you have
had your eyesight graded on the 20/20 scale
before.
If you haven’t, you have probably heard
other people saying they have “20/20 vision”
or even the phrase “hindsight is 20/20.”
The vision scale is so prevalent in American
culture that there’s even a TV news show
named after it.
Of course, if you’re from, for example,
Australia, you might be told you have 6/6
vision.
Turns out, the 20/20 scale isn’t universal.
So what exactly are eye doctors measuring,
and how can the scale be different in different
parts of the world?
After examining a large number of people,
American ophthalmologists decided on the 20/20
scale, saying that “20/20” is the normal
visual acuity of the average person.
What that means is that standing 20 feet away
from something, you can see what the average
person can see standing 20 feet away from
the same thing.
Take the Snellen eye chart, which is what
your eye doctor will usually use to judge
your eyesight.
The Snellen chart is the one that’s topped
with the big E and consists of 11 rows of
capital letters that get progressively smaller
toward the bottom of the chart.
You will be placed 20 feet away from the chart
(most doctors’ offices are too small for
this, so mirrors will often be used to simulate
20 feet).
The doctor will ask you to read out the smallest
line of letters that you can see from 20 feet
away.
Most people can read the fourth line up from
the bottom without any trouble, so if you
can do this, your vision is considered 20/20.
Now, obviously most places in the world don’t
use the Imperial system to measure distance,
they use the Metric system, which is where
the 6/6 scale comes in.
In this case, doctors are not measuring how
well you can see something from 20 feet away,
they are measuring how well you can see at
6 meters away (that is, 19.69 feet approximately).
It’s the same principle, just a slightly
different measurement.
Of course, many people will have worse or
even better than 20/20 vision.
These people will tip the scales a bit.
Back to the Snellen chart, if you can only
see the big E up top and none of the other
lines of text, you are considered to have
20/200 vision.
That means you see at 20 feet what the average
person can see at 200 feet away.
20/200 visual acuity and worse is considered
legally blind in the United States.
Alternatively, if you can read the tiny bottom
line of text on the chart at 20 feet away,
you have 20/5 visual acuity, which means you
can see at 20 feet that which most people
can only see at 5 feet away.
Most humans don’t have the ability to have
much better than 20/10 vision, with 20/5 vision
reserved for animals like birds of prey.
These numbers would obviously be adjusted
for the 6/6 scale.
That said, your 20/20 or 6/6 visual acuity
is not a measure of your prescription as it
does not take into account the nature of the
problem, only the result of it.
That’s why you can’t just pop in to your
ophthalmologist, read the Snellen chart, and
head out—they have to measure things like
peripheral vision, colour perception, depth
perception, and eye fluid pressure, among
other things.
Bonus Fact:
• The Snellen eye chart was created by Herman
Snellen, a Dutch eye doctor, in the 1860s.
There have been other charts developed, however,
which also might be used during an eye exam.
An example is the Tumbling E chart which features
capital letter E’s facing in different directions.
This chart comes in handy when young children
who don’t know the alphabet are being tested,
or for people who don’t know the English
alphabet.
Rather than say a letter, they can pick the
smallest line of E’s that they can see,
and say or point which way the “arms”
of the E in that line are facing.
Numerous studies have shown that this chart
and the Snellen chart come up with nearly
the same results.